right now hundreds and hundreds of
talented ballet dancers from all over
the country are in town for the youth
american grand prix it is considered the
american idol of ballet where future
star dancers are scouted christian
casares joining us in studio christian
you caught up with some of them today
ahead of their moment on stage that's
right brian well it's certainly an
exciting time for all these dancers now
we're specifically talking about ballet
dancers ages 9 to 19. now the goal is to
land a scholarship to an elite ballet
schooler get hired professionally by a
big company but for one local dancer
this competition is the start of her
dream
before i go on the stage my teacher
always says to relax my face so i like
rub my cheeks it's taken crystal huang
10 years of practice dedication and
mental focus to get to where she is
today a young ballerina with big dreams
i'm trying to
improve as much as i can every year to
reach my goals of becoming a principal
dancer at a big company
now this 13 year old las vegas native is
showing off her skills at rehearsals for
the youth american grand prix the
world's largest student ballet
competition they're all very talented
that's what i think so i'm excited to
share the stage with them and witness
you know history because who knows
which of them will become professionals
or what paths they will take hundreds of
dancers ages 9 to 19 from all across the
country are competing for a scholarship
with elite ballet companies in cities
like new york and paris catherine morgan
is a former new york city ballet dancer
and today her role as a judge has her
complete attention the ideal winner is a
dancer that marries both the technique
and the artistry so oftentimes ballet
can be very i don't know trickster with
turns and let's see how i can get my leg
but for me it's the dancer that also
comes out with finesse or with character
you have to like believe in yourself
like i learned through ygp that i can't
doubt myself ever and when i doubt
myself i never can do my best
well the regional semifinal winners will
continue to the finals next month where
the scholarships will be awarded for top
schools and companies and of course we
want to wish every single one of them
good luck